ciao ragazzi benvenuti nella puntata di
cucina buttata all'interno di questo
punto il bugigattolo ma la linea visto
che è proprio da questo bugigattolo deve
sapere cosa pensiamo di questa cucina
che stiamo utilizzando intanto che poi
cedere un attimo aggiustata detto ciò
iniziamo con la puntata di oggi ci
mancava da tanto tempo fare cose enormi
ed è proprio per questo che abbiamo
deciso di sperimentare un nuovo piatto
gigante non faremo cose assurde non
faremo cose lontane da noi faremo la
cosa più semplice buona del mondo per
vedere se altrettanto buona da gigante
sto parlando di un piatto di pasta
gigante al sugo gigante ma chi vuol dire
al sugo gigante come può essere un fungo
gigante è tanto la pasta gigante al sugo
banti cercando di basilico senza
riuscire a trovare
partiamo per fare la pasta gigante al
suo gigante avremo bisogno di 6 v fa 600
grammi di farina olio aglio rosso un
morolo botto sale e zucchero per
correggere parmigiano e basilisco sacca
solamente pesate nostra farina se invece
non ce l'avete come in questa casa di
l'intera di cui dovrete pesare a occhio
io sono particolarmente bravo nel pesaro
occhio se questo è un chilo e 600 grammi
sono corsi e al massimo aggiungendo dopo
la ceramica e proprio cioè 600 grammi
mano picchio che fa il muro il vulcano
il vulcano
ma la mia sa ancora con buon 20 21 l'app
repertamento lanciata da bagno tv canal
4 dozzine guardate arrivata anche a
cinque tazzine e guardate che i muscoli
o guidi più lunga da ultimo burro
forchetta minare posso dire 32 la perina
e poca dire che se dovrebbe ci sono
tante parole da parte tua vediamo alla
fine di tutto starà lì 28 almeno per una
volta sarebbe una prima ci stanno almeno
150 grammi meno lo scopriremo solo
vivendo
avessimo vinto solo che adesso fa dura
ancora che questo buco poi mi toccò poi
mi tocco da brother vizio si potesse
avere qua sotto
capito o non ammetto con lei campate le
faccio un'altra mentre in giro potete
rispondere anche voi ma solamente se vi
siete iscritti a questo canale avete
messo un bel pò nel senso questo video
gigante avete tintin nato
ecco io indignato la campanella e
notifiche per non perdere nessuna di
queste prelibatezze d'improvviso per me
la ricordo ancora guarirmi chi fu
d'improvviso quel silenzio tra noi
veramente massimo gianmarco scandire un
momento nel quale enrico se ne sta
prendendo una canzone che mi viene in
mente con d'improvviso e vabbè
bravissima ragazza fortissima rai
pallone un'altra fuori dall altro
missione perfetto mi tocco vasco rossi
levature adatta mi tocco l'america
magistrali già fatta mia madre ed io non
sapevo solo che pensavo a quanto
aiuteremo ad indicare un banale da una
putt unità più cazzo enrico a casa dare
una brutta notizia gianmarco ed enrico a
villa stia montando il palo a questa
milano e gianmarco ed enrico sul palo mi
faccio male no certo posso dire che
questo impasto necessitano di farina
sono ottimista
la parola e ci riuscirai con l'umiltà la
la la la la la
la palla un imbarazzante non lo so che
il progetto che dario tu sai che uomo
sono io che me la sto dicendo in ma di
certo palmette allenata no è una femmina
pesi e anche una femmina frigo quando tu
lo scoprirai morirai tu sai che uomo
sono io
questa per me è un brutto colpo questo
qui non mi licenzio ma voce dell'amore
temi ma se ne va tantissimo sono gli
strazi è stata insieme a lei non piace
[Applauso]
al timone tramite non solamente come
collegare praticamente a tutto il genere
musicale che ascolti brutta draw è
veramente banale questo suo commento al
fatto che quando incontrerai qualcuno no
no bravissimo non comprato da disney
subentrato dopo venerdì col crisma
quando mi con tre rai e angoscia
rammenta che mi posso dire qual e la
linea col cartone sopravvaluta thomas
tuchel dietro marco che siamo sempre le
veneri canale unico ma potete far
trent'anni fa di cartone
abbiamo rivisto durante il blog max a
parte l'ho proposto io e a mia discolpa
dico che sto parlando di realizzazione
del cartone che è magistrale la storia
ce li rilegge jjj plus è una roba che
per la mente racconta come in realtà
spesso noi abbiamo tutto quello che ci
serve ma semplicemente non abbiamo gli
occhi per apprezzarlo abbiamo delle
distrazioni che non ci fanno bene che
rischiano di far del male agli altri pur
di uscire dalla noia della quotidianità
con in realtà poi venga in mente
aspettiamo che la pasta riposi per una
mezz'oretta passiamo subito al sugo
ragadi il suo gigante facilissimo da
fare poi bel po di spicchi se non è così
va bene schiacciamo olio quadra sul
fuoco iniziamo a fare un soffritto
neamente sta esagerando è in realtà
penso che ne accorgerebbero 1 andiamo a
rimuovere la gli opa si butta l'aglio
nolo sgranocchi e poi vivaci la tua
amata dove sai che secondo me dovremmo
fare una una ricerca con la campania
fateci sapere qua sotto se mi piacerebbe
vedere una ricetta fitta kabanga
sciacqua tina buttiamo dentro il mio
obiettivo per questo esperimento di cosa
quale è riuscire a trasformare questo in
un piatto di pasta non vuol dire che
debba essere tanta pasta il più grande
alema ingrandito al po di zucchero che
poi sale però così è poco chiaro ragazzi
da cucina però italiana ci butto anche
un po di basilico non sempre dosi e
nonne non andavano addosso ogni realtà
anni non ne facciamo questo e le
buttavano col cuore
e fanno andare senza paura che dovevi
mettere più farina luogo crudo gianmarco
allora perché ma io so dire che noi non
stare bjorn meglio quello della pizza a
crudo che voglia degli spaghettoni e
lunghi così non ce la fai
quante volte le persone hanno pensato
che tu non saresti fanno tanto di noi
e quante volte hanno avuto toto mai io
già lo so che sarà i bricchi ossia
cricchio cricchio non mi ritengo
soddisfatto magis ma che dico se ogni
giorno non è ciò che è entrato dove si
aspettava il piatto del gigante golia
rimane dieci volte più lungo del tuo
bene almeno tre al quale dei due ex puoi
dire che avesse fossero più grandi a
questo mi aspettavo io do se fosse stato
così lo spaghetto deve essere con quella
migrare capito io quello che aspettavano
nella nota che lo spaghetto sull'apple
huseyin carrello spaghetto gigante e lo
spaghetto medio sinceramente non so che
tipo di pasta mangiate voi è però fatto
sta che questa qui e basta enorme per
quanto mi riguarda mi sembra pappardelle
lo conoscete il film a tre morse eccoli
però tre morti
vuoi uscire dalla porta grazie analogo
kevin bacon presente quello dei cristi
transformers bravo questo piccolo
mugnaio stupendi che ti ricorda pronto
non è proprio gigante ma se pensate che
per un solo piatto di pasta gigante
folle per l'm orsini rondi ok suoi la
che la pasta fresca si attacca set h
certo è presto
ricoh è troppo tardi aspettiamo la pasta
fresca di cucina subito lo sai che
toglie il segreto di non aiutare chi non
vede l'ora di farsi il treno orsini si
rompe qualcosa che avevo detto avevi
ragione tu hai sempre avuto ragione tu
si tu sei migliori e rivotu sequenza
capito tutti che io non sono un cazzo io
sono solo lo spettro di un cliente anche
passaggio pallina prevedere come stiamo
anche questa è la pallina prendi una
cultura forse ma fai male incazzo patti
chiari amicizia lunga
toast altro posto incazzi già sbagliato
la pasta e ho chiuso un occhio ma io ho
due occhi guglielmo cioè una tecnica e
non è spegnere il fuoco
il mestolo se metti di legno e
trattamento
[Risate]
3 pronta la carta in uscita
l'importante distoglierla con questi
spaghettoni agita ieri davanti alla
faccia il salto il saldo ma guarda che
sto facendo ma va a posto questo con un
forchettone norme sembra un piattone
enorme io lo mettete le foglie di
quercia hanno purtroppo un sapore del
basilico quindi basilico ma queste basi
nino tritato basilico tritato bar e
nicco 6 sul pezzo un filo d'olio a crudo
enorme perché giano gigante grattugiato
bene dobbiamo lavoro sono veramente
enormi 3 spaghetti sono tipo mi metto a
questa il sogno cioè nicosia bel gioco e
prendete uno spaghetto che dovete
arrotolato se facessi calare noi
dobbiamo che non tremo dai bulli non può
fare queste figure
polito di male punto spesa cioè gli
spazi chiusi è infinito
il morso è ottimo ma ognuno è molto
buono dai sono riusciti tremors inoltre
morosini promossi promossi promossi se
volete farli anche voi in questo march
un esercito sicuramente forma tortellino
nei pochi turco iraniana pende una cava
benissimo ed è the likes se volete
vedere di tutti i danni del live
scrivere questo canale tv che vi
mandiamo un bacione grande ci vediamo
giovedì alle 14 con un nuovo bio ciao